this is where i would bury stalin
and murder her if i did it
now all i have to do is roll her into
the grave cover it up
and make sure i take everything with me
yeah i just i sort of wish there was
that strong female lead
something yeah someone likeable yeah
i just can't sit back and wait for
permission from some guy to make a movie
you know nobody wants you to make a
movie as much as you want to make one
yourself
just make it happen i would walk people
through how they would commit the
perfect murder
you're my scary girl
i'm scouting locations for the next
scene of the film
ground floor apartment perfect i'll come
back later
when it's time to complete the next next
step breaking and entering when the
occupant is home
lean in baby murder is probably not
realistically depicted on
television so i would do some googling
first
all the best serial killers are
unpredictable they look at the criminal
profile they're forming
and they strike outside of it i could
unwittingly reveal too much about myself
psychologically by my choice of targets
it's pretty clever right
there's no movie that is worth hurting
someone for
they're just real benefits to killing a
bad person if you get a good movie out
of it that's an additional advantage
i'm so good at murdering it just sucks
that i can't get the credit for it
you're not gonna stop me you can't
anticipate me
you can't predict me
[Music]
i'm living my best life
[Music]
[Music]